Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 104th episode!
BAU BAU!
Extra silly today, you think?
Oh, Ruffians.
If only you knew how silly it is today!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us for
The start of your week, another FUWAMOCO Morning app!
The start of your summer maybe!
Episode 104!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians will be joining us today for the very first time!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A FUWAMOCO!
It's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
This is your first FUWAMOCO Morning!
Hopefully it'll be a wonderful start to your day!
Get you right started on the right paw.
It's 11am for you!
The start of your morning!
It's still the start.
Yeah!
I'm excited to see what, you know, this week holds, what this summer holds for us Ruffians!
A new month.
Yeah!
Lightning.
Well, uh, the next bit is a bit frightening too.
It's Friday night, but... It's summertime, you know summer's supposed to be fun!
Ice cream!
No.
Water, no?
No, nothing like that.
We had another...
Pero Sighting.
No Bikini Pero, that would be terrifying, Ruffians!
Well, let's take a look!
De-den!
I don't think this is a Bikini Pero, but we're not too sure.
Would it be better if it was Bikini Pero?
You are really brave to try out and get through Friday night of Fridays.
Did you get through all the nights though?
Every single one!
It looks like there's something extra nasty there though.
Yeah.
Pero.
You won't leave is your game.
You know, we were seeing a bunch of crazy things we were playing.
You know, Golden Freddy?
I don't know, we saw a lot of stuff.
Yeah, we got killed by nothing too.
I don't know.
Not fair!
Yeah, well, maybe that's...
Extra lucky or maybe extra unlucky.
Extra nasty, that's for sure.
Extra nasty peron.
We hope that you were able to get through all his nastiness.
It can be a bit much.
You know, maybe a pudding for him can help things a bit.
Or for you.
But good job being brave!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO, we're pretty brave, right?
Oh, he's making the game better!
That's an interesting take on things.
I don't know if I agree with that one, but okay!
Ruffians just want to make every game fluffy and fuzzy and a little bit nasty, I guess.
Is that what you like, Ruffians?
Fluffy, fuzzy, and nasty, huh?
We need that game!
No.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it makes it extra terrifying.
I guess it's true.
Yeah.
It's not wrong.
Speaking of terrifying, terrifying in a terrific sense.
I always get confused about that.
Terrifying.
Oh, that's terrific, but then terrific, terrifying, but terrific, good terrifying.
I wonder why, huh?
I get confused.
Ruffians!
The tickets for hololive English's second concert, Breaking Dimensions, went on sale last week!
How did you do it?
It was quite the battle for the tickets.
Terrifyingly.
You got yours!
You did!
Yeah, it sold out so quickly!
It was a blood bath!
There were tens of thousands trying to get their paws on only a few tickets high!
You got one!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations to the extremely lucky ones who got the venue tickets.
But for those who didn't, we hope that you'll be cheering us on the Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy way through online streaming tickets with SPW and Spawn.
Right!
And you can get them right now too, Ruffians!
You don't need to worry.
No more battling, you know.
Don't forget!
So you have to get it now.
That way you don't forget!
The Northwest Passage is very far!
It's not easy, okay?
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm FUWAMOCO!
That Ruffian will be cheering for us as loudly as you can!
Dancing around and jumping along too!
You know when you're at the venue, or you have a watch party with friends, or you're joining us on the other side of the computer screen.
Please make sure that you BAU BAU lots, okay?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Breaking dimensions!
Like that, okay?
That's what I want to hear, okay?
You promise?
Yeah.
Gotta forget.
FUWAMOCO's first stage performance!
Wow.
You know, I think it goes without saying, but we're gonna bring our best.
The performance of all days.
Oh, our performance!
I'm fuzzing this one.
Oi, Moco-chan.
We will settle for less.
BAU BAU!
We're excited!
Yeah, BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Well, Ruffians, we sure you heard the big news.
But, over the weekend, the beloved, beloved, very beloved, friend A, she announced... A-chan!
Yeah, A-chan, she announced her retirement and that she would be spending her last day at hololive at the end of last month.
Yeah, otsukaresama desu.
Right, it was really bittersweet to say goodbye to her after a very, very special seven years here at hololive.
Right, Moco-chan?
Moco-chan, you're getting teary.
FUWAMOCO will miss her so so much.
She was really lovely and welcoming to us as the new demon dogs on the corner!
I wanted to spend more time together.
There's never enough time, right?
Yeah, but we'll treasure the times and the conversations that we had together with her and all the wonderful things that she told us, reassured us with.
We're wishing each and all the best for the next step at FUWAMOCO!
Moco-chan, right?
We're gonna be the strongest twin demon boy band ever, right?
Strong!
Not crying!
No!
No, right?
My cheeks are not wet, though!
Yeah, she had an amazing impact, right?
Yeah, but you know FUWAMOCO will be strong and that way we can make her really proud, right?
We'll make you proud!
Thank you so much, A-chan!
Thank you, A-chan!
Thank you so much!
BAU BAU!
Lots of good memories.
Let's cheer her on!
Let's keep the memories in our heart, okay?
BAU BAU!
Legend is forever, forever, forever!
Today is the first day of July.
First day of July.
Somehow, July and August are officially summer.
Right, Ruffians?
It's officially summer.
You agree with us, right?
Summer has started.
Summer, summer!
Do you think it's summer?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, summer!
When it's cold and it's hot, it's summer.
When it's gonna be summer, it's summer.
July is summer.
August is summer.
Can't disagree with it.
Well, you think of summer, Ruffians, you know, ice cream is a big one.
Ice cream is good.
Ah, sunscreen because the sun is really strong.
Important!
Yes!
It's also fun in the water.
Water?
Right, you might have seen Ruffians, but hololive is having a collaboration with a water park and us, FUWAMOCO, we're participating in it!
The Liyue Village Rotten Pie.
You know what this means, right?
Too many pies!
Look at all of us.
I need to scroll because there's so much of us.
You know we have Ayame-senpai, Mari-sencho-senpai, Nenechi, Muna-senpai, Kubo-senpai.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Who's next?
Inose-pon.
The cute, the cute, the bond.
Grassy pond.
It's kind of nice, though this is like a swimsuit debut, right?
What is this?
Swimsuit debut!
They are... Aren't they cute?
Cute!
It's cute!
Very cute!
Hey!
Why do I see Ina-senpai?
Ina-senpai's pretty cute though.
Moco-chan, don't get jealous!
Tickets for the Leofu Village Water Park go on sale on July 5th at 12pm, but there'll be also a lot of special photo areas and other special things hiding around the park.
Special voice messages from us that you can only hear there too!
Of course!
Of course?
There'll be special merchandise and special food!
And special life slides and more!
And we'll also be entitled to the fish travel water slides, so please come ride it with us, okay?
I'm so excited!
Everything is special, okay?
Yeah!
Especially because it's swimsuits.
Right, Ruffians?
FUWAMOCO.
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO swimsuits!
Do you think Muna-senpai would switch swimsuits with me?
What do you mean?
Me?
No, you would fit that, Moco-chan.
What?!
Ruffians.
Yeah!
Ruffians!
With this.
I can't say that Mococo isn't sexy, right?
Right?
Look!
You have little floaties there, Moco-chan.
Are you sure?
It's time for this again!
They're not floaties!
Look at them closely, okay?
The proof is right there!
Ruffians, definitely go check it out if you want to see our best doggy paddle too!
BAU BAU!
I think you look good doggy paddle, okay?
Yeah.
But, is the doggy paddle sexy?
Is a doggy paddle ever sexy?
That's up to you.
We'll think about it.
BAU BAU!
There's so many exciting things going on.
This is the water park you have to go to.
Wow!
Also, Ruffians, you know, our new kouhai Justice just debuted.
And actually, we got
FUWAMOCO School!
BAU BAU!
Let's check it out!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I live for the impeccable journalism!
Yes!
Yes, in Elizabeth and her very first Archive Karaoke stream, she did well.
She sung Advent's original song, Rebellion.
In case you didn't know it, which I was very happy to hear.
But I have to admit, when I woke up, she was already done.
So then I checked out the archive.
I was like, oh, Rebellion!
And I clicked it.
The timestamp.
Thank you timestamp, Ruffians.
And I was very surprised because this is how I woke up.
Ruffians!
Elizabeth is a monster!
She shocked the entire enchilada to rebellion in one breath!
Try it right now, okay?
Ruffians!
A, D, V, E, M, T. Time to get this party started.
Fire, fire, light the fire brighter, higher as you desire.
Ow!
I can't.
Ruffians.
We're a bit tired too.
Yeah, we're a bit.
You know, it's the end of the day.
We're very tired too.
Yeah, is it even possible?
You try, Ruffians.
You give it your best shot.
You sing it as beautiful as Elizabeth, which would be something.
And you do it in one breath, okay?
It's just not possible.
But it is if you're a monster like Elizabeth.
Monster.
And that's how I woke up.
Fuwawa was like, Moco-chan, listen!
She's a monster!
She just took the entire beginning to her ability in one breath.
I was like, hi.
Yeah.
Hi.
We're demon dogs, Moco-chan.
We have to do the same.
Okay.
Doggy paddle.
Lots of doggy paddling and then we can sing Rebellion in one breath.
The entire song.
Take that, Elizabeth.
Entire song.
That's the goal, okay?
BAU BAU!
Good luck with all the karaoke, Elizabeth!
Big ones, very big ones.
We have to do some more doggy paddling.
It's a bit hard, huh?
Yeah.
Wow, Ruffians!
It's one day.
It's been a little while, but it's the time of the week, Ruffians!
You know, a new FUWAMOCO Morning, a new week, and a new challenge!
Moco-chan's Natto Challenge!
Is what I want to say.
But Ruffians, after the 100th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning and many many displays of braveness, Moco-chan's natto challenge is coming to a close today.
I win!
Moco-chan, your thoughts?
I don't know Ruffians.
I think I've grown quite a lot.
I've grown a kinda lot.
Before I couldn't.
Just the smell was enough to not be good.
And now I can sort of eat them.
She can sort of eat them.
Do you agree with this statement, Ruffians?
How about a pizza challenge?
PIZZA CHALLENGE AFTER MIDNIGHT RuffianS!
What are you trying to do, Hai?
I don't know.
Yeah, but Moco-chan, you know, I do agree that eating natto at midnight, right before bed, is a little bit difficult.
Ruffians, it's too difficult for me to eat natto right before bed.
My tummy...
No.
Yeah.
But Moco-chan, you promised that you'll make it as homework, right?
You'll give Ruffians regular updates on how the natto eating is going.
Yes.
She said yes, right?
Right!
Midnight Pizza Challenge!
I don't know, what about last time?
That's hard on a midnight Tommy too.
I don't know, Ruffians.
Ask Mei-senpai to do that, okay?
Not me!
Okay.
Wow, Moco-chan, do you mess with your homework with the Ruffians regularly?
How are you and Nanatoi getting along?
Yes.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Every single day we're challenging ourselves.
Who could say every single day is a challenge?
That's a different meaning, darling!
BAU BAU!
Again, thank you so much to all the farmers for their delicious natto.
And Ruffians, we hope that you try it someday too, okay?
BAU BAU!
You said goodbye to the natto.
But let's say hello to our Doggie of the Day today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
We have... De-den!
Anyo!
Hi!
I'm just having some nice dreams, hi!
Chiyuki, you know, I know Senpai's really cute, but this Anya here... So cute!
A bit sleepy, huh?
I'm just gonna fall asleep on my big booty.
I'm sleepy.
This looks like a good pillow.
I think so.
You know, when you're tired, anything's a good pillow, right?
I'm gonna take a nap now.
Yeah, just like a hard bone can be a good pillow too.
Good pillow.
Doesn't matter if you're sleepy.
You're sleepy.
How do you think I'm about BAU, Moco-chan?
I can tell for sure that Anya is having some very sweet dreams of delicious bones.
And hopefully, you know, once maybe this pillow disappears, maybe there'll be more pillows.
More pillows in the future!
Hopefully not the ones with feathers.
Bone pillows.
BAU BAU!
And next, Ruffians, you know it's the summer time.
It is perfect to go outside right now as long as you remember your sunscreen.
It's not too hot outside.
So let's take a look on the little adventures you've been going on.
Let's take a look.
De-den!
A tree!
This tree looks like a knee joint!
That's what it does!
It's like an elbow.
What's the difference between a knee and an elbow?
Arm bend.
Knee bend.
Leg bend.
Arm bend.
Knee bend.
Oh, arm bend, leg bend?
Ruffians!
Do your knees look like this?
All barky and wassy.
I should hope not.
It looks like a tree.
Yeah!
We gotta rub some moisturizer on the barky like that.
Yeah.
Stop the barking.
I'm gonna pull off the moss too.
FUWAMOCO-chan, you're ready, right?
I'll pull off the moss!
You feel insulted?
Pull off the most gently.
Gently.
And then when you least expect it... Pull it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing such a cool channel with us!
We got a question from the Ruffians.
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Cecilia Imogreen went to amusement arcade on her debut stream.
A math question?
Do you have any memories or feelings about amusement arcades?
FUWAMOCO!
We love arcades so much!
We go and play games together with Mama Puppy!
You know, just having fun on the weekends and stuff.
Just like special times, you know?
We had lots of fun, uh... Ruffians.
We did beat some games, okay?
Yeah, we put enough coins in to beat games.
Yeah.
We did, okay?
You might not believe us.
Yeah.
Uh...
Yeah, another one finding, finding Idle Master, the original arcade Idle Master 2 many years after!
Yeah!
Didn't cry.
No.
No, definitely didn't.
You know, playing Dance of the Gods.
Yeah!
A game where you become a train driver.
BAU BAU!
There is one, one arcade game that I'm always, always looking for.
Played it once.
Which one?
Space Adventure Cobra the game.
Get the psycho gun, you can play with the psycho gun!
I want to play with the psycho gun!
Yes, it's so fun!
You know the ones where you're on like a bike and then you're like flying and then the ones where you're in like the raft and you're like... The ones too!
So many fun, good memories at the arcade.
We go to arcades so much!
They don't really feel real though, right?
There are so many memories at arcades.
Like an alternate reality.
The first time we went to the arcades, Fuwamoco wasn't crying at all!
We also went to arcades with Mama Puppy.
Lots of I.Q.
memories!
Time crisis.
BAU BAU!
Protect the arcades.
Thank you so much for all your submissions today!
Thank you for the very cute puppies recently.
Thank you for the wonderful photos of your puppies.
Send us all your questions.
Your cute walks, too.
And your scoops, too.
There's a lot going on.
Especially in hololive English right now.
Cute questions, cute walks.
Not cute Pero.
If you happen to see Pero, I guess you can let us know what's going on there.
Yeah, but he's not gonna be cute.
Please make sure you use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
OK?
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have De-den!
Portal 2!
We're playing together up front, so you know, we had some postponements last week.
This week, you know, it's FUWAMOCO GANBAIDEN week!
GANBAIDEN!
So we're gonna do our best Ruffians!
We're doing it with demon dogs!
We're ruff!
Yeah.
No.
But if we do have to postpone something or cancel it, it's because FUWAMOCO, we are gonna fall apart.
Okay.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our schedule.
We have a schedule for this week.
Like I mentioned, it's FUWAMOCO Ganbare Week!
Yeah!
We have Portal 2 on Tuesday at 6pm PT.
And on Wednesday we have FUWAMOCO Morning followed by a super chat reading.
We can finally chat!
A super chat cause we're gonna chat and it's gonna be a super time and we're gonna read some super chat as well.
Thursday early at 3pm PT at 7am JST.
FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be having a Rock n' Rawr Party Mini plus Q&A at Anime Expo!
BAU BAU!
If there are any Ruffians there, please come by!
We're gonna be singing a bunch of- We're gonna take some of your questions, too.
There'll be more details out in the next little bit, so keep your eyes peeled, okay?
BAU BAU!
And then later that evening,
At 5pm P.T.
at 9am JST.
It's a little bit different than our usual time.
Be careful, okay?
We're going to be having a club all together with Advent and we're playing old school RUNSCAPE.
What are we playing?
RUNSCAPE.
RUN RUN RUNSCAPE.
I don't think there's any cars involved.
Chickens.
Cooking chickens.
BAU BAU!
And on Friday we start the final day of the week with FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah!
Followed by at 8pm, a little bit later than usual, at 12pm JST, we're gonna be playing Crab Game together with hololive English, who will be a part of it, huh?
We'll have to see!
You won't want to miss it!
It'll be the first time we ever play Crab Game, huh?
Right!
Crab Game!
I don't know what you do.
And on Saturday at 2pm PT, 6am JST, FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be special guests at Good Smile Company's panel!
It'll be FUWAMOCO there!
We're so excited!
Yagoo-san will be there and I found it!
Let's smile and be there too.
It's like I don't know what to say, huh?
Right!
There's so much to say!
What should we not say?
We're gonna do a Shiori and go on a tangent.
This is my first video and I love it so much!
I love this so much!
FUWAMOCO We're gonna do our best!
We have something there!
At 4pm.
And then shortly after!
Minecraft!
FUWAMOCO, we're going to continue our Minecraft journey!
At 6pm PT, at 10am JC, like our usual time.
And then Sunday is our homework day.
We have a bunch of stuff to do, huh, Moco-chan?
So much stuff.
Thank you, Ruffians!
I know when we shared our schedule on Twitter, we mentioned this as well, but FUWAMOCO and Rock n' Rawr Party will be back this month in July!
So we hope that you'll look forward to that.
We have so many songs we want to sing, Ruffians!
Oh, we've been holding it in for a long time.
Yeah, all the songs we want to sing.
The boy group has to hold a bit.
Yeah.
So thank you, Ruffians, for meeting and for looking forward to them.
We're gonna have a bunch of fun this month.
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians joining us today in the archive.
Today, here is your FUWAMOCO word.
It's BAU BAU!
Do your BAU!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for a new FUWAMOCO Morning to start off the week.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ballin!
BAU BAU!
Tiana.
Panda Ruffian.
BAU BAU!
Lollipop.
Potechi.
BAU BAU!
Salviagi.
MWK.
BAU BAU!
Barbeque Box.
Yuppie.
BAU BAU!
Violet Gelato.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!